I've been at Venmo for two years,
and for the first 22 months,
at Venmo, I was on the iOS team and
I built a large part of the Apple
that exists currently today.
And now I'm on the strategy team,
we're focused on exploring different
monetization strategies at Venmo.
The Venmo iOS team decided to
rewrite the Venmo app in Swift.
Around the same time as WWGC 2015,
Swift 2 was just announced and we were
watching all these videos about all
the cool things you can do with Swift.
At the same time, quintessentially,
our product design teams were discussing
new UIs and new UXs and
in the Venmo app.
Also, at the same time, our existing
Objective-C.code base was becoming very
unmaintainable, building new
features was taking a long time.
If we ever wanted to do any design
changes to the app or different
flows in the app, it would require
massive refactors because of the fact
that our UI layers and our model
layers are so deeply coupled together.
So, one day after the one
of the WWDC sessions,
all of us came back to
the San Francisco office and
just started whiteboarding what of Swift
version of the Venmo app looked like.
We made an API layer,
we made a UI layer and
we just opened up our computers and
started building it.
This wasn't like an official project or
anything but
we started we kept doing this for
about a week and a half and
came up with a bare bones
version of the Venmo app.
kind of just like an experiment to see
how a Swift only version of Venmo app
feels, and how much faster we think we
can iterate on a version like this as
opposed to the current
version of the app.
We got to a very good point
in those two weeks, and
finally told what we were working on and
how this code base that's going to
maintainable for a very long time.
And it's also going to enable us to
write features much faster, and because
of all that, they decided to get on
board and we started building this app.
Objective-C will stick around for
a very, very, very long time.
All of you like it,
the foundation and I think all of
Apple's frameworks are actually
written in the 100% Objective-C.
I don't think Objective-C is going
anywhere for an extremely long time and
I think that having some knowledge about
how it works is extremely important.
I do think that as time goes on,
more and
more Objective-C developers will be
writing Swift more and more often.
A lot of existing companies that
have 100% Objective-C apps will
start catching the Swift train and
start building all their new features
in Swift, which I highly recommend.
What I don't recommend is just rewriting
an app, a perfectly good app and
in Objective-C and
Swift because it's going to be a very,
very, very long project
with very little gain.
One of the largest challenge of doing a
big rewrite is the fact that during that
time of the rewrite, your team can't
really build new product features and
if you are building new product
features, you have to build it twice.
Once in the existing app,
as well as like in the new app.
The nice thing is that when you build
it twice, you can actually see how much
faster you're building it in a new app,
which is quite delightful and
kind of proves your point to the rest of
the team that this is a good decision.
But that was definitely the most
difficult part about doing this rewrite,
but when we were being conservative on
new features in the app during this time
and the ones that absolutely had to
get in, had to be written full times.
We're still working on it today,
it's almost done.
The scope of the app is also changed
a lot since we first started.
That said,
the entire team is working on it.
And whenever some project does come up,
like a product feature that needs
to come out,
one of us will move off the core app,
rewrite app and start working on that
project and then work on it twice.
Once for the old app and
once for the new app.
If we were hiring a new
developer at Venmo who
primarily will be writing Swift, I
think that them having some Objective-C
knowledge coming in to Venmo
would be really valuable to us.
It would also differentiate
them from other candidates
that might only also know Swift,
which is really important.
Though our entire code
base will be 100% Swift,
we do have a lot of dependencies
that are Objective-C, and
sometimes you do have to go
into them and maintain them.
We would want them to know
the syntax of Objective-C primarily,
as well as some of
the nuances of Objective-C.
For example, Objective-C variables
are by default always optional.
That means that opens you up to a lot
of errors and runtime bugs which
you don't have in Swift, and so it's
important to be even more careful, and
check for nil before you're adding
a variable into a dictionary.
A lot of our third party dependencies
are still in Objective-C,
some of which we have
open source ourselves.
So going back into those dependencies
and updating things is important.
Knowing basic Objective-C
syntax is very important.
Knowing how to do anullability on it
to make sure that your Swift code
plays nice with Objective-C
is also very important.